what up reject nation i like to yell at the
microphone for no reason guys we're going
to watch moon night episode 4 today if you
want to catch our full length reaction watch
along where do they go Coy the patreon time to
jump that's why Coy's not part of it i'm not
support them emotionally become a superject today
that's a check out everything we got over there
but if you can't do that leave a like that mean
a lot and tell us your thoughts on episode
four because if you're watching this you've
probably already seen it prepper boys thanks
for helping us edit these down let's get to it
oh no jesus
would they not check inside the truck
the one place someone would hide
only what you can see not leaving our own truck
you gotta treat him like a t-rex
you guys suck at your job you know we're
going to need mark yeah exactly see she gets
i hadn't hadn't disappeared from your life already
yeah i mean whatever suit was his best feature
wasn't it didn't even have that anymore stephen
right now i need to yell at layla
he said goat earlier i wonder
if harrow has goat spies
when he pointed and said goats maybe it's nasher
and the other thor one i don't trust that goat
oh you're in love with my wife i appreciate
your concern mate i really do lay one finger
on you got it from here i swear to you stephen
i swear i need a recipe for a protein shake or
something shake made out of sand
you smell like him of course he
does i mean why wouldn't you right
mark's trying to yeah you from conscious that's
why he's been pushing you away he he thinks
conscious wants you for his avatar and he won't
let that happen that's where i just thought i felt
like you should know that oh stephen you're a good
guy what a good guy i would have taken the kiss
blocking himself virtue i don't need
protection what i need is honesty
miss knight honesty yeah being honest
oh buddy smooth operator you know
down okay first before i believe
thank you what was belay i still
can't tell when you're joking or not
a plus
i love their two experiences that kiss that
they're just like i'm standing is that
bast the black panther guard so if they
just sprang to life right now and ask
me a riddle for passage i'd be thrilled
it's a maze it's amazing
they were so smart to go with that personality
leaving the show it's amazing and this long
line ending in a spiral is the tongue the avatar
would be on its voice that's clever holy balls
you think we'll go to the afterlife in this
one could oh god is that fresh blood oh yeah
oh yeah let's get some canopic jars
this is what kevin feige's like we're pushing
boundaries the remnants of violence i'm just like
i'm just saying what i see and see lots of bones
and blood going that way so i'm just thinking like
all right good
it makes me laugh how there was barely any moon
night and now he doesn't have
the suit in the fourth episode
yeah yeah yeah we can go this
way oh no leila get up there
that's someone with no tongue oh [ __ ]
creepy
oh yeah
oh dude you gotta go into the nose
dude let marks take over
let mark take over
my
this is exciting this is a better
uncharted movie than uncharted
this is this show just feels like a
theme park to me i love it so much
ho ho
what's happening here she got grabbed
and pulled back and then again
i just want to know what's happening
hopefully she landed on beds okay
there's no ledge your hero can't
catch that's why conschu wants you
her being sane and as formidable as mark
he's she's definitely a better avatar
yeah oh this [ __ ] guy man
he's not going around that ledge with
those shoes though not those glass shoes
oh wow look at that look at all these
relics it's going to be apocalypse in there
another oscar island i think we're looking
at the long lost tomb of alexander the great
or king the conqueror alexander was
the voice of ahmed i'm gonna try
something mr
your father was murdered by mercenaries
and no one knows who they were today
mark remembers everything that
happened that day but one man
stands out a man with a fuchsia
scarf made by his daughter perhaps
i do hope you find closure wake up
that's not nearly enough information
to find closure with them man
there we go yeah later gators
i'm talking to you mark right now what
happened to my listen today you can
of course not but you were there i was there yeah
i was there how did he die my partner got greedy
and he he executed everyone at dick's site he
shot me too i was supposed to die that night
that's the reason that we met you just
had it guilty conscience they're here
let's be another way out go find it i'll hold them
off she's a hell of an actress man oh absolutely
nice oh [ __ ]
i can't save anyone who won't save themselves
oh my god make the deal again
being reborn and baptized
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna go to the sunken
place a hell of a shot it's beautiful
wow oh i got nipple chills
the four matches change yeah
that's young mark spector can you tell
oh there it is i want your history
you're doctor stephen grant
might be strong oh [ __ ] feels like
a 90s tv show next one we've got beans
i can't believe they're doing this
22 don't be afraid to speak up b-22 come on
everyone it's going to be the straightjacket
shot it's going to be the smallwood
lemire shot jacket this is beautiful
wow is my blowing
i did not think they would do this it's
been five times this week it's a lot um
she's got the turkish delight again
we won
i won we have a winner
yes i know that you're having
a great deal of difficulty
[ __ ] i hope you don't mind but i i took
the liberty of borrowing the film you brought
it was how many times would
you say you've seen that movie
approximately i like the villain
the plot makes a real meal out of a lunar god
and didn't you say that you worked for one
production value of that film i can't imagine
that too many other people have seen it
and all i'm asking of you is an
honest assessment of your situation
this is awesome god damn i know what
you're feeling you can be healed i know
don't hurt him all right
so good i love it what's the
last thing that you remember
arrow shot yeah yes exactly exactly
all right we gotta get out of here
oh come on gotta know open
it is it jake open everyone
nice wow that was awesome that was the
best one yet i did not think the show
would go there that was wow ooh i'm
like so like sweaty and uncomfortable
it's like legion vibes too it was so intense i
genuinely don't know what reality they're gonna
land on they could really go a lot of ways do
we think it's jake and that third sarcophagus
i think it's tony stark tony stark's back
tony stark is just in there trapped in a tomb
i like that episode a lot back to my a's that's
that was incredible i have theories i like that
pace theories will wait whose voice was that at
the end i don't know i don't think it was hers
what's the corresponding animal and envisage
for the god of music and love oh yeah
could be is it do we know any hippopotamus-based
gods i don't that's that's why yeah i'm like is
14 odd is that the whole that's what i thought
we were going to get was that yeah actually
when i think about this show it seems like
it's mainly based off of this this company
this is what i would because this is a
cinematic i think i was like wow this is
very much and that's so i was like surprised
to be like oh damn we're going all the way
going whoa because i i think the bendis
malevolent is really solid as well but
it's not as approachable and i also think the
cenkevich stuff is a lot of the visual aesthetics
they're doing but it's not as approachable either
i mean stephen grant is like very different i'm
surprised they went there i really like that i
don't know it's not like the fight club thing
where you've got a twist that is like now i know
i mean they gave a really good there was one solid
hint as to what's happening he says it about like
getting passageway when they're going through and
they see the horus sign he says they're going like
a passageway to hell or something oh they're on a
boat do you think that water in the boat that's
what the rocking was like in the on the lights
and so do you think the afterlife is i think
there's no i think he's there he's number one
the clapper board is like issue number six or
seven which is the actual introduction yeah
number one that was the one i was like that's
what they're gonna do i think we should hold
them back because i feel like they're just holding
the issues let's just let's just read the comics
but no i think that was the early
clue in in there that's that's great
and that's why i was like huh but i didn't think
they would do it yeah drifting into the afterlife
and then that wake up was genius yeah i don't
think they're on a boat but they could be on like
something they're in water that is like a
water rocking that i think that's what it's
reflective of it could be way wrong but that
seemed like to be the biggest indicator man
they're in a truck that's falling while
they're also here in the hospital i also was
not expecting the externalized two marks and i was
not expecting jake and i mean mark and uh and and
i just forgot come on the biggest episode of
the season it's jake is the one i want to see
because we've got mark stephen grant
guys sometimes he was doing a [ __ ]
guys i'm so tired my brain just shows like that's
the time that's an authentic time you are dragging
that's what it looks like
that was like your credit
joke i can't tell the difference between boys
save our credibility you don't know comics
[ __ ] it's just funny to only read one comic run
of moon knight this is the exact thing i told you
guys i think they're basically off this run i was
so like overwhelmed with all this stuff i was like
there's a packing a lot and i told you guys this
is the right no you just need the one i only gave
you like 30 issues yeah and they've done about
14. that's definitely not the same thing though
no but it's just a lot yeah this is definitely
not the same there's a clearer connective tissue
to one specific run than there often tends to be
yeah and it's just exciting because john and i
really get to have that feeling all the time like
i'm validating my weight yeah look at me there is
i can't tell you the amount of times i've read
comics and i've been like they don't even do 99
of what's in the comments that i read
so you do get that gratification you're like oh
that's so cool it feels great when you're like i
remember that from my meetings i remember yeah
but most of the time we don't get to say that
so that's why it's exciting drink it in it's
not like we're cocky and we know it all it's
like this is the rare it's also literally
like 100 issues and they use like 12 but
throughout the 100 so you have to read way
more to really get that feeling of like yeah
and it's exciting because i didn't expect them
to ever do that in the show i didn't either i
didn't think they'd go that far down the rabbit
hole where i was like whoa because we're already
into you know very interesting gaps in reality
with them changing identities i didn't know if
they'd go full meets self existentially yeah and
also reality to the level of life where does the
show go in five and six with this much up in the
air earlier in the episode he's talking about like
a riddle for passage which seemed like it was
references to the moment my mind went to a comic
book specifically dealing with something with
passage he talks about protection in the afterlife
so that's why i was like oh maybe we'll actually
go to the afternoon hear him exclaim in the
episode rewind yeah if you'd like to see that
moment it's 13 minutes in or so i'd be surprised
if they did it exactly the same way because
there's different plot setups to it the a b
and c of it is different than the d e f of
it you know what i mean so i think it could
also the visualization of the thing
we're talking about is very different
so they could go that way or not i don't know
they did some visuals in the last episode there's
this there's this thing in the comic called
the void basically even though that wasn't
what we were entering into in the last episode
yeah definitely had the cosmic array look and
the color palette yeah exactly so it definitely
felt like very referential to it but instead of
getting bogged down and things that could be heavy
potential spoilers for what's to come let's just
talk specifically about what's going on here i
liked it way more than episode three i thought it
was a really that was really strong like yeah this
is about what i liked it had that swashbuckling
tomb raider uncharted esque vibe i'm not talking
about the movie uncharted no you really liked it
but i'm not talking about the movie uncharted more
about like the video game and i think that the
way they've woven these interpersonal conflicts
while moving the adventure along is really strong
i can imagine that there's a part of the fan
base that's probably disappointed with the
way this show is going because you barely get
moon night in here like you've barely got it
moon i haven't noticed you guys have mentioned
that a couple times and like it hasn't been a
thing for me because i don't read comics for
the punching oh aren't you sophisticated no
but like i read it to look at the drawing i
just i liked the ponder some like you know
existential musings on reality more than i like
the throwing punches so i don't mind that moon
knight is used as a means to an end as opposed
to the characterization being the importance
yeah no absolutely i think that this er what makes
it strong is i'm more invested in steven grant
and mark spector to the point where i don't find
myself going once he could have turned into moon i
want to punch it should always be treated as like
cherry on top or necessary for plot development
the way they use them here like i don't i don't
miss it i'm not like where's the suit that's
when the show's most interesting it's that someone
that shows most interesting to me and i think the
way they've really established the relationship
was right by the way i was totally right i just
predict that about layla was totally right yeah
i was close yeah he did he did not kill his life
but he was there and i thought you know it worked
out i mean the show alludes to like yeah he should
have died that night and that's when which is
fun for the comic fans but beyond that like i
think even if you haven't read the comic you're
like oh that must be the night when uh conscious
saved him because episode one is that a very event
yeah so it references the fact that like the same
day leila's father was killed and mark was there
as a mercenary it was also the same day he made
his pact with koncho and that's also the event
that the people the the not cops when they throw
them in the back they reference and show photos
of like that's all this event we've relived in
various episodes it's cool out there like as this
mystery unfolds you also get like the backstory a
little bit clearer without actually cutting away
to it and i keep wondering if we're are we ever
gonna see that actual scene i like that we're not
because then it feels like we're living through
their adventure of it instead of flashbacks
always make me feel like i'm watching something as
opposed to in real life we tell stories of a thing
and therefore you're with these characters as soon
as you do a flashback then you're suddenly like
oh right i'm watching a medium like i'm watching
an art piece instead of watching a life does that
make sense yeah give me mike flanagan's moon night
yeah lots of time version well i keep wondering
too with this like plot reveal that they have
here of the psychiatry psychiatry hospital what
approach are they going to take because as much
as we've referenced a comic that it's definitely
pulling inspiration from is it going to be the
case where there are actual souls trapped there
like you have this one guy there who sort of
looks like the what is that job called john when
someone isn't like gold paid an outfit and i feel
like you know the name of it for some reason
that's what it's called everyone knows but me
makes sense pretty aptly named exactly what it
is isn't it living statue forget what they call
the actual little totems that they imprison the
gods into but that's yeah it's like a little human
version of that but i do like the parallel of like
a busker being like a god that's imprisoned as a
living statue that's a fun thing well beyond
that it's the guy who's the living stature in
the first episode who mark who stephen talks to
and then it looked like one of the guys there
was that guy might have been that
guy yeah so i don't know if it's like
these are actual people who are also in this
other world but then what threw me off is
the fact that mark is interacting with steven as
two separate entities who can look at each other
okay but maybe this is just some weird world
that mark is trapped in now in his own head
and then their mess and then like egyptian gods
or whatever the imprisonment is happening is
messing with him specifically or are there or is
like layla also there but doesn't remember she's
layla you know so that that's what i'm wondering
i don't know which direction it's going to go
i also wonder if mark and stephen are alternate
realities of the same person because we haven't
really explored that in this and marvel universe
is starting to do multiverse theory what if this
is a multiversal world where there is
a steven and a mark that are separate
leaning into the variants and leaning into all
those concepts it is an interesting question
two hours make it happen it does raise a lot of
implications because you do see you know they're
doing partly playing on his own psychiatric state
because it's like okay here's everything we've
seen pretty much every prominent face here's an
origin for all those that could motivate this
being some kind of fantasy or you could argue that
maybe it's like a parallel almost rhyming spirit
realm where not everybody is aware of their earth
circumstances or something like that and i like
that at least right now that is mysterious and it
seems like certainly whatever is being presented
here as a mental hospital scenario isn't true but
i like that they've drawn it in a way that is very
sort of you can you can look at it and interpret
it and anticipate it turning out multiple ways
but it still complements nicely with everything
else that's been going on because if you look
at you know the motivation that arthur harrow
and his disciples have shown as much as there
are those like movie moments where they get kind
of dastardly for the most part like the mission
is still one of like we've got to guide people
and help heal them and blah blah so like it it
makes sense that the counterparts might you know
translate into the people running this joint for
the powers that be it's a nice adaptation but also
a nice strong metaphor visual plane to kind of
move forward from well what is ahmed's deal again
i'm totally freaking blinking right now i'm hungry
too but it's off it's uh she basically is the
one that like punishes people before their crimes
which is his whole issue with it i don't remember
what she's actually the god of that's yeah
so could ethan hawk in the psych hospital be ahmed
messing with him but why would ahmet be doing
that and why wouldn't well she looked like an
alligator no no i'm not saying that the hippo was
i don't know what i'm saying that i don't know who
the hippo was i say ahmed's in disguise as harrow
yeah maybe in this psych unit thing yeah it all
depends on on what implications how much power
that you might have in this realm carries over
to the other row because i'm like if she's got
all the control here and is able to orchestrate
this elaborate fantasy to imprison mark seems
like she could get a lot done on earth you know
yeah she can make this happen yeah i need to deal
with it she wouldn't need an avatar yeah she's
gonna get all that done yeah yeah but maybe not i
mean maybe it is you know some or maybe it's like
she's puppeting his uh astral form or something
i don't know i also feel like with marvel shows
usually it's that episode five cliffhanger that
makes you go like how do they wrap it up it's
cool to have this but at four like what's the
last movie of this because there's a two-hour
movie left effectively like why does this all
we're in a very different place i think it would
be very disappointing for a lot of people if
this was all just in some guy's head i
don't think they'll do it was all a dream
so painful for everything it would just upset
people oh you just committed to that and there's
no actual moon night like yeah if that was
episode five maybe that could happen but i
feel like that's why this happened on episode
because they have two episodes of the actual
reality so it is not a film a student thesis film
of like oh he's dreaming yeah cause at five we
have to spend a little bit of time unraveling
this assuming it could be true and finding out
it's not and then climax and daniel mullen six
that being said they you should stay here for
a whole episode i think i think you gotta like do
what the movie glass failed to do but it might be
fun to do like 40 of the 50 minutes here yeah at
the end you transition back to really make mark
wonder if he is crazy and like because i felt very
paranoid and uneasy in that whole scene like i
really enjoyed the way they had the outside of the
lenses being disoriented and they played with rack
focus and they really made you feel pulled and i
definitely like that was the disorientingly almost
paranoid high experience yeah when i feel like
this could make it a good bridge to complementing
and ultimately tying up that question from the
first couple episodes which is that you know did
can't you choose you because you're broken or did
he break you in choosing you and maybe the answer
we will discover through this is sort of neither
and maybe you know in having these two personified
personalities now interacting separate of their
host body which is good therapy maybe yeah maybe
then they can see that it is neither and they can
use you know again uh the struggle you know with
the personality as yeah part of the strength or
come to realize that self-actualize that you know
i mean this could be the void you know
where like conscious imprisoned into yeah
that could very much be like where he's and then
we get a personification of him yeah yeah and i
think i think either he's in that sarcophagus
or jake is jake lockley egyptian cab driver
he said speak there yeah i think it's very
possible and maybe even likely like we meet jake
in the next episode he has a fourth personality
doesn't he depending on the continuity so many
different i don't think he has more than like
six ever at once but he's got a lot going on
and then but i think the three main ones are
gonna be representing the show cause there's
so many threes in the post-credits team there's
three oscar isaacs in the first scene in the
uh in the uh museum you see his reflection and
it's him plus two they've made three a recurring
number so i think jake lockley is coming by the
end yeah i don't think the third is moon night
because we have two moon nights in mr night and
moon night i don't think the third is conshu cause
they've always been representative of the image
of oscar isaac so i think they were trying to
mislead us by thinking that kanchu was the third
because the posters like the posters had mr knight
moon knight and then kanchu but i think it's going
to be three oscar isaacs and therefore jake will
come or it's the guy who fights werewolves in
space that's gonna be episode six go into space
shameless connecting tissue yeah yeah i mean
what's interesting is he only signed on like
oscar isaac didn't sign on for more after this
yeah so if we get more moon night it's going to
be case by case for him trusting the script and
wanting to be the character again so it's going
to be interesting where this ends because it
needs to be opened enough for more oscar isaac
but enough closure that we have a story muhammad
said that moon knight's here to stay and there
will be more i i want that and i think oscar isaac
was smart so he could renegotiate for me and make
money he's getting to do like between the khanshu
overwhelm in the last episode and the sh and the
shifts between him steven so seamlessly like this
is an actor's dream if you're as talented as this
actor well funny enough actually as much as
we've talked about it i don't really miss
moon night or mr knight or feel like i'm being
deprived of those characters really at all and
i think this episode brought that around really
beautifully because this episode had the gradual
pacing that i wish we we kind of collectively
expressed a wish for the previous episode to bring
and so this one really wonderfully traversed
scenes added some icky horror stuff and then
brought it back around to a really mind-bending
emotional place all that was like great i'm just
with this and i don't even need the suit well
it also did the thing we wanted like we were
talking about how that had to do a lot i think
we needed moon knight and mr knight in the last
one so this one could not have both so this was
the answer to that and it's interesting because
muhammad's directing style is so capable to have
that tension and action densely and then you get
justin aaron who love like inverted framing and
a lot more like avant-garde style shots and that
suits this episode much better whereas mom had
suited the last episode better so i i think it's
really smart actually i was worried at the top
when i heard there were three directors on this
because i was worried that the difference in
episodes would feel jarring but it's positively
jarring their styles suit each storyline better
yeah i think the swashbuckling of this episode
is great i think uh the actress who plays
layla do you know her name i don't me i think
not sexist haha there's the first scene with
arthur yeah especially and and the way they frame
that they're talking across a chasm beautiful i
forgot steven grant's name thank you very much
character name on the show yeah that
shot was stunning that was like a
desktop background yeah and then the close-ups on
it like yeah so stunning it's like a desktop pack
it could be my facebook cover i want to see it
often it's a desktop on my laptop i want to put
folders on top of that i'd like that to be the
dark void that is me opening my computer because
it makes me sad i want to get used to that image
and never appreciate it i want to feel sorrow yeah
her performance was awesome when yeah when she
confronts stephen grant too or mark in that moment
this was like a great epic i probably ranked this
as my second favorite what's your first the first
episode your favorite first episode is still my
favorite i would say this is my second favorite
episode that lasts like 10 minutes i'd say i
also loved her in the last 10 minutes where
you're from his perspective theoretically and
how she's like manipulative and selfish and
how mark might see her that way like if we're
looking at mark's view of her where she's like
we'll share this it's mine i won like that whole
play on how he might perceive her is fun because
we've only seen her as selfless like she's
been killed jada pinkett it's all her fault
right guys that's right so everyone says right
the only oscar i want to talk about is isaac
the smacks in episode three when he was like he
like opened his fist and then palmed the dude i
was like again the only oscar we're talking about
his eyes it was a pretty contained episode they
dropped pants at what's going on but it's uh i
mean we really really don't know if they can't
just pull from a comic they would have to do some
different it's like the civil war thing they're
gonna nod to it heavily but the thing that made it
especially different though but then again that is
kind of like the comic too with the two but that's
why i'm thinking multiversal is an option to make
it unlike the comic i think they could go variants
and multiversal stuff because that's where marvel
is right now yeah i don't think they will like
that's not my expectation i just think that option
i wanted to say it out loud because if it lands
there won't be like but i don't think that's what
they're doing i just want street cred from right
i do think if this sticks the landing this is on
par with loki for me again like the way they're
navigating this dense of material is insane what
makes me curious is like if this is ahmed's doing
like it would be weird if it was just some other
god who was doing this or something right if it is
ahmet's doing why would ahmed be doing this to him
when konchu's not even a part of him anymore
unless conscious trapped there too and that is
that realm where everyone's stuck i don't think
ahmed's causing that afterlife i think that's
the afterlife i don't think ahmed's responsible
for that so this is just like the like kind of
like the egyptian afterlife and that's how he
perceives it because oh that's what i was ever
saying protection in the afterlife because the pen
the pen is a pen to him the pen is blue no no no
no no the pen is a pen to a harrow and the pen is
a chew toy to a dog the afterlife is going to be
perceived as mark would perceive it versus how the
egyptian gods would perceive it ah yeah the pen oh
i think the perception of what reality
is is literally in the palm of your hand
and then the next episode dr strange walks through
and be like there's a lot of variants in here
gets you all out of here
i put all my faith in the pen i was so excited
about my pen moment the pen is mightier it's a
fatalistic this pen will only ever be a pillow
me martin i think we need to fight games
psychiatric perspective there's only one reality
where this isn't a pen perspective i think i think
that's it i think the pen is perspective itself
i'm very excited about that yeah there's a lot
of depth here man all right it shows a weird
day to film this yep we're all a little slim
i think these are the longest reviews we've
done after episodes yeah it's the show's fault
did it say it's too good it's too good man
we only reach about a half an hour yeah i'm
gonna look for an egg salad sandwich excellent
i want to go like meatball marinara sub no you
wow that's what i want around this that's
crazy yeah i'm leaning in it's a lot of
i want density i want protein i want i'm all in
just a tube full of buffalo you can sell them four
days into a diet cause i've been eating salads
and juices and now i'm like meatball marinara
pro time oh buffalo chicken
artichoke pizza too though
yeah he didn't stop talking for like a minute
subscribe click that bell we watched what we
were saying this time around we'll catch you
guys soon let's do a patron of the day shout out
olivier hamelin look what your name means and
guess what it's olive tree it sounds a lot like
my fiance's name olivia which means olive branch
and a way you two should be together when i watch
the show moon night and i think about you know
layla can be with both steven grant and mark
spector i could be the mark specter in the
situation and you could be the stephen grant
that's right buddy i'm inviting you your
sexy reject into a polyamorous relationship
with us i think the time has come for us to
take that next step just by virtue of your name
what does a branch connect to a
tree you are the tree trunk to our
relationship so olivia before you say no just
know this i will gladly never get involved in
the bedroom if that means i can emotionally
have you because that's what matters most i
don't know what you look like i don't know what
you behave like i don't know what you sound like
i don't know anything about you really but i
do know that we are a perfect triangular fit
he's sexy so i'm a [ __ ] please don't cancel me